okay we're doing it it was one of Nikes
tag lines that did not make the cut
fun fact hi guys welcome to this youtube
video my name is grace Helbig if you did
not know now you know your life is
different now so lots of things have
been happening I'm wearing a tiny
turtleneck I feel like squirtle I want
on my tumblr and ask you guys what kind
of videos did you want to see and some
of you said you wanted to see make up
ground wake-up related tutorial I know
about the Kim Kanye Taylor Swift drama I
thought I would combine those ideas and
do a Kim Kardashian Taylor Swift
inspired makeup tutorial for you Wow now
you might think that Kim Kardashian and
Taylor Swift have two very opposing
makeup identities and they do it's like
when their makeup identities get
together it's like which will be very
exciting for that to happen on my face
I've been looking at a lot of pictures
of each one of them and I think I've
come up with some sort of hybrid makeup
look who knows we'll see what happens I
haven't tested this but I have ideas
we're going to try them here we go I'm
gonna start with my eyes first
it always does a very dark relined okay
like how are you a smoky eye and Taylor
I think likes to play with more like
gold and that sort of thing so first get
some eye primer on my one eye primer
well I want this look to last no we're
gonna skip that I'm gonna use this
goldish color on my eyelid oh yeah smear
that all on this is the same gold that I
used in my hot dog makeup tutorial so if
you don't think I'm an expert at makeup
tutorials you can you know suck a wiener
oh that made a fun disgusting visceral
noise I've been saying the word visceral
lot lately so I've lost a lot of friends
and celebrities really pack on the
makeup so do not be afraid to get
excessive just like the drama that's
happening right now between them just
make it really irrational
nonsensical and just so excessive there
we go
Wow cute thank you now the both of them
love a great cat or as some might say
[ __ ] on the lid so we're gonna go for a
really strong cat eye with this look I
use my gel liner instead to get that
strong fierce cat eye I'm just gonna
draw it in thick we're also gonna do a
little bit under I mean they're both
very high fashion and they're both very
strong so the stronger the better I've
got a little away from me but I don't
hate it and I'm gonna just go with it
which i think is probably something that
both of these ladies have sent in their
lives at some point about something so
now let's do the other eyes oh-wee
oh-wee I'm gonna just get a little artsy
with it see what happens
I know Isis put a line here short - go
for it okay they would say to - really
like you know pop your eyelid I shadow -
just put a little pop of like white no I
think those eyes our artistic apps so
one huge thing that the Kardashians do
Kim especially is they really like to
highlight under their eyes I'm gonna do
some highlighting under my eye just
going to go for a triangle shape of
highlighter under your eye you want to
illuminate it right like Illuminati
under your eye will blend that in a
second but now we're gonna move on to
skin I have some foundation on already
however these two women just have the
most gorgeous skin of all time my skin
needs some help so I'm gonna just pack
it on and I have a tendency to get
really red really easily and I've heard
that green combat redness so I'm gonna
use some green first okay so the next
thing that we're gonna do is contour and
Kim and all of the Kardashians we all
know love a good contour I can see that
Jenner also uses some light shading so
I'm gonna go to Kim route on this and go
real heavy with my contour okay we're
gonna carve out them cheeks mmm very
bell curl the chin I was going to carve
out forehead also carving out the neck
is a super huge trend and if there's one
thing that Taylor and Kim both love its
trends next and last we're gonna move on
to lips now I see
Kim she takes risks with a really dark
lip but Taylor has her signature red so
I'm gonna combine both of those okay and
I'm definitely over drawing my lips
which is very highly Jenner but she's
related to Kim so that relates okay
awesome
now we're gonna go with the signature
red I'm using Lilly Singh's boss from
Smashbox get him over drawing a little
bit and there we go here is my final
product this is my mashup of Kim and
Taylor's makeup looks let me know what
you think thank you guys so much for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
give it a thumbs up and let me know what
other sort of makeup tutorials I should
attempt on this channel I'm no expert
but I love trying I try so hard don't
forget to subscribe if you enjoyed
yourself at all during this video or if
you hated the entire thing you should
subscribe because you know punish me
with your attention I don't know oh this
actually work yeah it looks done